[Musique]
j'ai envie de m'enfermer pro-gym enders
cité n'est pas vide il faut des
bailleurs kg 2
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
marie c'est incroyable parce que c'est
jj hadid
si t'as foutu dehors c'est la star des
stars c'est la star des stars
évidemment je n'ai pas reconnu parce que
je suis moins d'assurer je connais rien
tu croyais que c'était rené habib ammar
mari s'était dit cette année elle m'a
les mauves beige book beach ça vire vers
la plage alors ça a été repris par tous
est ce qu on a regardé infecté repris
même à l'international à newsweek regard
des quizz marie saint tite
non mais sérieux c'est ouf non mais il
n'y a pas il ya aussi times via guardian
j'ai 6 mm c'était hier henri michaux
américain qui a 6 millions de
téléspectateurs non c'est un 3ème
surtout à new york je suis une très très
grosse taille honneur je m'en vais
sortir s'arrêtent ça oui et ça bien de
ses excellents pour chat d'une arme
bien sûr d'ubs énorme pour chanel c'est
pas bon et n'a pas besoin de multiplier
les images dans le monde entier c'est
fantastique j'ai fait moi je pense que
chanel et on la remercie devrait la
remercier langage et bien sûr et c'est
vrai que c'est une pub immense 1 pour
chien et ludivine c'est une super pub
pour chanel mais je comprends que voilà
a forcément la sécurité ce duo-là live
elle aurait pu faire non elle avait peur
après moi je pense que les sarthois est
très content ça sera ça bosse du canada
oui j'imagine dans tous les défilés à
venir le portrait robot la photo et 6
henry de la sécu tu vas chercher sa
gueule partout sur tiffany c'est un beau
coup franchement bon foot bête mais ce
que je mets dedans mais tu as fini en
garde à vue après il ya quelque chose tu
vois on connaît pas la presse dit ça en
fait le plus haut encore ce genre de
moment c'est de pouvoir s'échapper et
ils étaient ils avaient tellement peur
du scandale que je commence à relais
laissez moi partir laissez moi partir ou
appeler un peu les anciens me laissais
ma partie enfin j'ai dit laissez-moi
partir ont appelé la police ils ont
appelé la police
à
[Applaudissements]